if you want to hear about how one dark
story point is hidden in the background
of this movie then stick around to the
end of this video welcome back to things
you missed today I'll be covering one of
my favorite psychological horror films
that kind of flew under the radar
because of the sheer volume of great
horror movies that came out in 2016 I'm
talking about to the boy this is one of
those movies that can be fun to look
back on because it's only after learning
of the twist that some of the things you
missed start to make sense so as usual
with these types of movies allergy to
make sure that you've seen the movie
before hearing me analyze it so with
that in mind let's get into the things
you missed when Gretta arrives at the
house for the first time she's still
asleep in the car and the driver after
bringing their stuff has to wake her up
apologies this first interaction that
she has is symbolic of the time she
would spend there most of which is her
being frightened by the man on the other
side of the mirror she finds that the
house is seemingly empty until she meets
the grocery delivery man Malcolm and he
shows her around the kitchen the crates
that he uses to deliver the food are
from Broadhurst farm grocers Broadhurst
is one of the many examples of the
initials bh which come up again and
again in the story the boy she's hired
to look after and Brahms heelshire has
the initials B H the letters are carved
into the rat traps set up around the
house and the book that Greta later
reads aloud to Brahms has a character
named mr. Brocklehurst BH more on that
later she meets the family and they
explain the rules like how she has to
play music at an uncomfortably odd
volume most likely so that the real
Brahms can have some time to move freely
possibly to exercise
she is also to clear out the rat traps
daily because mrs. heelshire is afraid
of the rodents getting into the walls
where he's living
it also gives a plausible reason as to
why she's to discard any uneaten food in
the sealed chests
he gives Brahms the opportunity to feast
on her leftovers yeah he's very much
with us well at least he gets points for
honesty I also find it interesting that
he tells her this stuff while they're
outside because the rooms inside all
seem to be connected by these tubes
which carry the sound
which I suppose is only on Solon and
again this system is perfect for Brahms
to keep tabs on her he can listen in on
her and make sure that she's following
the rules no matter where he is in the
house while also making noises to try to
convince her that the spirit of Brahms
is present in the house to cover this up
the heelshires have added a rule that
she can't have any guests over and only
Malcolm can come in to make the
deliveries this way she never becomes
aware of the way that the sound carries
because for the most part she's the only
one making any sounds if you were
wondering if the heelshires are in on it
or if they too were being fooled by
Brahms consider this before they leave
they take a moment alone which I'm
guessing was for a final face-to-face
with the real Brahms would you give us a
moment to learn to speak to Brahms
privately sure I'll crank up the volume
right here where you can actually hear
bronzes voice
[Music]
you can't make out what he's saying but
you can tell them isn't mr. and mrs.
heelshire he wants you miss Evans he's
chosen you if you have the back story
that we later learned tells us that
Brahms used to play with a young girl
named Emily but one day she was found
killed in the woods it was most likely
Brahms who had always had some issues
so the heelshire started a fire and
faked their son's death to avoid the
consequences they let him hide for years
inside the walls until they couldn't do
it anymore that's why they pretend that
they're going on holiday where they
really just end up offing themselves out
of the guilt for what they allowed
Brahms to become they also seem nervous
as they're leaving probably because
Brahms has become too powerful and they
don't know if their vacation cover story
is gonna hold up I think Brahms a grave
marker is another clue it says he shall
not perish but have everlasting life
though I'm not sure why they would leave
a clue to the secret that they're trying
to keep guess they just wanted a little
inside joke between the two of them the
penultimate rule is Brahms is never to
leave because looking back on it the
illusion that the dolls possessed would
never hold up in the outside world it
only works because the real bronze is
able to emerge from inside the walls
while Gretta isn't looking so all of
these tactics are enough to plant the
subconscious seed in greta's mind that
Brahms could really be alive in her
first dream scene the shot begins with
us looking through a mirror and it is
through the mirror where Brahms would
eventually reveal himself there are many
shots like this that seemed to be coming
from bronzes point of view whether he's
stealing her stuff while she's in the
shower
spying on her through a keyhole or
otherwise the dream ends with a hand
reaching out through the wall to
attacker so perhaps some subconscious
part of her suspected the truth as a
possibility after things start to get
weird around the house grete gives in
and starts following the routine that
the heelshires have laid out for her
which includes reading aloud to the doll
everyday she reads a selection from Jane
Eyre a 19th century British novel there
are a ton of parallels between the story
of Jane Eyre and Greta's story and the
boy but the most notable part is when
Jane becomes a governance which is
essentially the role that Greta is
filling up the house and meets a man
named Rochester one evening Jane
discovers that Rochester had been set on
fire in his sleep and it turns out to be
a mad woman in the Attic who was
responsible
Jane saves Rochester's wife just as
Greta goes back to save Malcolm from
Brahms and the boy if you ever read Jane
Eyre I'm sure you can find other
parallels as well but I'm gonna move on
to the dark truth behind Brahms and
tensions in the movie
in a Q&A with the screenwriter Stacy
Munir he reveals that Greta wasn't
brought in to be either a girlfriend or
a mother figure to Brahms but rather a
messed up in between of the two we get a
pretty good idea of this when they
discovered the real room with the
makeshift sack doll wearing her dress on
the bed but what you may not have
noticed is the used tissues I'll let you
draw your own conclusion with that the
doll also has a head full of hair it's
possible that at least some of it is her
real hair because we see her notice a
chopped portion upon getting out of the
shower earlier in the film the arms are
covered in what seems to be refrigerator
letter magnets
maybe the director's clue about the
in-between status that Munir was talking
about that brings us to the last rule
kiss goodnight I can only imagine given
everything that's been presented that
Brahms did not plan on stopping up the
kiss it certainly gives new meaning to
this line well we've had a number of
potential nannies come through already
Brahms has rejected them all though they
weren't nearly as young Wars pretty
it was also hinted at that Brahms
exhibited a sort of sadistic behavior as
a child many rumors in town seem to
think he was responsible for crushing
the young girl Emily's skull and that
does seem possible after seeing the
superhuman strength displayed during his
rampage he also has an array of animal
traps and possible torture devices
hanging from his ceiling I think that
means that the pH carved into the rat
trap that I mentioned earlier probably
does stand for Brahms and the sad ISM is
one of the many psychological issues
that he has where else would he have
gotten the blood used to leave the
message for greta's ex-boyfriend Cole
there are plenty of secrets hidden all
over this movie so let me know what you
might have noticed in the comments and
if you love horror don't hide behind
that mirror come out and subscribe to
seize these worlds for new Horrors every
week to bring that death battle for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
you